I'll tell you a great story about him
and running and how huge this victory
was so when we finished up my book tour
the last stop that we did was in Orlando
and I had DeSantis as my special guest
so we went right into Disney and and did
this show there and they had protesters
and they're screaming and all the usual
nonsense but I'm sitting in the green
room with the governor Just the Two of
Us for about 10 minutes before the show
and we're just mostly you want to talk
about baseball actually we're just kind
of yeah like it wasn't about politics
he's just a decent dude and uh and I
said to him I said uh you know Governor
you're going to win this thing by 15
points he laughed in my face he said six
or seven six or seven and now he won by
20. I mean think about that he thought
six or seven he said six or seven and
that would be huge and the guy won by
20. do you think that do you think that
he said that because he didn't realize
how much of an impact he had made
how much people really appreciated what
he was doing and how the rest of the
world does he not view himself the way
we've we view him in order for him I
mean I've had dinner with him a few
times he's he's a he's he's normal he
would sit here with but does it make
sense what I'm asking like yeah like
does he not see what we see but that's
great though it's hard no no yeah that
might be the ultimate secretly assistant
want to get too cocky like of course
he wants to be level-headed and just be
like moderate and just be like listen
keep my head down and work my ass off
hold on the reason I asked that is
because if he doesn't there's there's
like you know all the guys here we're
not where we're at right now because
we're not competent we're very secure
but it doesn't mean it doesn't mean you
can't be humble at the same time but the
reason I asked that my concern is that
does he not see himself like if he says
something like that okay then if you
really believe that then you don't you
think that you may not be able to be
president I think it might be you can't
win the person it might be something
like this I think you know as someone
that just got here right that is so
proud to be here and so vested in in not
only continuing this place but making
sure that it lasts for a long time I
came in with so much energy and and I
see now so many I'm sure you guys all
see it with new neighbors and everything
else people that come in and we're like
holy we fled we fled we're refugees it's
amazing
you know I just have my one suitcase and
you know and uh and I think maybe what
he didn't see that he probably now after
20-point win sees is that all of the
people that came here not only I mean
they all voted for him everyone voted
for him but then every it was just
working here and you take it for granted
when it's working so then all of these
new people come in and they're so
excited about it and I think maybe the
he couldn't quite quantify what that
excitement was you know because for him
it was like we're gonna stay open we're
supposed to stay open I'm not gonna put
you out of a job you're not supposed to
be out of a job I'm gonna send your kid
to school so I think maybe there was a
little bit of a a disconnect but to your
point I think that might be the beauty
of the whole thing of course if you're
looking for more honest and thoughtful
conversations about politics instead of
non-stop yelling check out our politics
playlist and if you want to watch full
interviews on a variety of topics watch
our full episode playlist all right over
here here and to get notified of all
future videos be sure to subscribe and
click the notification Bell